Four,
three,
two,
one.
And we're live.
What's up bro?
I'm doing okay now.
Ten seconds ago around the area where I
wanted it to be that way it's more
natural sometimes,
like some of the best stuff gets said
off Mike.
So we figured now how to do it where
people get in and as soon as,
pretty much as soon as we sit down,
we started talking.
Um,
no complaints.
So you contacted us after the Leah
Remini interview,
right?
And you wanted to get on and you have
this book that you wrote called ruthless
with the correct pronunciation.
Is Cabbage,
miscavige,
Ms Dot Kavin.
The actual name of the book is rootless
scientology.
My son David miscavige in me right now.
Let me,
let me just say this before we get
started,
because scientology,
this is the first time I've ever been
contacted.
They sent a,
uh,
an email to my publicist and they have a
rebuttal to what you wrote and their
rebuttal is that a website?
Ron miscavige book dot Com.
And they want people to know about their
website,
which is scientology.org.
And they have a statement.
This is their statement,
Ron miscavige is seeking to make money
on the name of his famous son,
David miscavige.
Oh,
David miscavige is taken care of his
father throughout his life,
both financially and by helping him and
even the most dire circumstances.
Ron miscavige was nowhere around when
David miscavige ascended to the
leadership of the Church of scientology
mentioned by and working directly with
the religions,
founder l dot Ron Hubbard and entrusted
by him with the future of the church and
he father exploiting his son in this
manner is a sad exercise of betrayal.
Mr David miscavige has far reaching
vision and unrelenting dedication.
Has brought the Church of Scientology to
where it is today,
guaranteeing it's future for generations
to come.
Scientologists worldwide love and
respect Mr.
Ms Dot for his tireless work on behalf
of their religion.
So that's,
that's their statement that they wanted
to say and I feel like it's only fair.
You know,
we had Leah Remini on and we have you on
and I've had a Louis Theroux on and look
at.
I feel like I don't know the story,
but anytime a father is so disconnected
from his son,
they have to write a book about him.
It's a sad time.
Do you feel like that?
No.
You don't feel sad at all?
I don't feel that.
I just woke up one day and said I'd like
to write a book about scientology and if
I can give you a short encapsulated
statement,
I think we could a nice
groundwork for the whole interview.
You mind if I do that?
Sure.
Okay.
I was a scientologist for 42 years.
Were you raised in it?
No.
I got my family in in 1970,
but I was in the church for 42 years.
The last 26 and a half years.
I worked at the international base in
Hemet,
California.
I escaped from that base on March 25th,
2012.
You escaped?
Escaped.
That's right.
I had the plan that escape for six
months.
We can go into this in more detail,
but just let me give you this short
story.
About a year and a half later,
there was a private and guest
investigator caught by the name of
Dwayne Powell,
who was around the corner from my house
looking at a house to buy so he could
spy on me from that house and they just
know shit.
So a lady in the neighborhood som and
she thought he was a drug dealer or up
to no good.
So she called the West Allis police and
Nick Pike came out and confronted the
guy.
He gave nicky some shit and nick said,
hey listen man,
you're under arrest.
Do you mind if I look in your car?
So Nick went to the van and opened it
up.
And then the trunk,
there were five license plates from five
different states.
There were two handguns,
a stun gun,
two rifles.
One fitted up with a silencer in 2000
rounds of ammunition.
So they arrested the guy,
they took him in for interrogation.
And then his son came looking for him
because his son was a partner in this
business.
The father's name was Dwayne Powell and
the sun was Daniel Powell.
Daniel came looking for his father.
And by the way,
if you want to hear these interviews,
they're on Tony Ortega's website,
Tony Ortega to underground bunker.
You can hear what I'm telling you.
Okay.
So Daniel is telling me,
you know,
how they operated.
They were getting paid $10,000
a week to follow me and report on my
doings from 8:00
in the morning until 8:00
every night.
An incident happened
in Janesville,
Wisconsin.
What do you do?
Like what could you possibly do that
would be worth studying?
Is it just a freak you out?
Like that's what I don't understand.
Like if you follow like if I fall,
Jamie,
you know what?
You know what I'm going to get.
I'm going to get Jamie looking at the
Internet.
Jamie watching basketball.
Maybe Jamie goes to the gym.
Maybe Jamie goes for a run.
You.
Jamie goes on tinder and does a little
right.
Right swiping right.
Okay.
You could get out of watching them.
It's not like you're out there burying
bodies.
No kidding.
Anyway,
listen,
let me continue because it just goes on
show.
They're interrogating them.
That's Nick Pie.
And there was an alcohol,
tobacco and Firearms Agent,
Rick Warren Hankins,
and because they were concerned about
that sort of theory that hey,
maybe they're out to hit me because I am
the father of the chairman of the board.
Right.
So then Daniel,
the son is being interrogated and he
said they,
they followed me to a town called
Janesville,
Wisconsin where I went shopping and all
these grocery stores dark.
This is very
detailed.
I'm telling you this is what happened.
So I come out and I had bags of grocery
and it was the summertime.
So I had a pocket tee shirt on.
I bent over to put the groceries in the
car.
I taught myself and was going to fall
out.
I grabbed my left chest.
They're looking at me in the van,
which they had been following me and
they saw me.
The father called his contact and said,
listen to.
It looks like the target is having a
heart attack.
What should we do?
They refer to me as the target,
right?
Oh Jesus,
no shit.
And they get a silencer and fucking 2000
rounds of Ammo.
All right.
Okay.
So they called the guy,
Greg said,
listen,
let me call you back.
A couple minutes later,
a guy come on the phone,
identified himself as David miscavige
and he said to them,
listen,
if it's his time to die,
let him die.
Don't do anything.
Don't intervene.
That's my son [inaudible].
Alright,
well it didn't just happen,
right?
I mean,
you didn't,
you didn't.
I want,
I don't want to interrupt your story.
You feel like it goes on,
but I mean,
your relationship with your son didn't
just start there.
So it had to.
It had it go sour.
Who knows shit,
right.
Listen,
my relationship with David when he was a
kid was incredible.
I mean,
we got along great.
He was
a snappy,
a little kid.
He was just very bright,
great sense of humor.
Uh,
just,
I enjoyed his company,
but as he grew older,
as you got into scientology,
which I got him in,
by the way,
I can get into that.
How I got him in.
He then started acquiring power and I
think he went from Dr.
Jekyll and Mr Hyde as an example,
when I worked on staff,
he never referred to me as dad.
He called me run the base that I lived
on in Hamot.
It got to the point where if you wanted
to send a letter to somebody,
you had to write the letter,
put it in an unsealed envelope,
two security guards would read it,
see if there anything bad in there that
I shouldn't be saying,
send it back and I would correct it when
it was okay.
Then they sealed the envelope and send
it out.
If I wanted them to call somebody on the
telephone,
I had to have somebody to listen
on the other extension and this is by
his orders versus just how scientology
notch,
not how scientology works it.
He is the undisputed dictator of
scientology,
so this is is Antara doing.
That's the way he wanted it to run
scientology in 1970 when I got in,
which totally different than what was it
then it was like for a free spirit,
you know,
just very lost a fair,
but you did courses.
You could come in and do things that
would actually improve your ability to
communicate,
to have better interpersonal relations.
I bought the book,
I bought dianetics and 1994 because I
moved to California and I was really
into self help books and stuff like
that.
And I saw one of those,
a late night infomercial ads.
Yeah.
And I was like,
well,
this looks like,
you know,
the reactive mind,
hey,
I want to have control of the reactive
mind and uh,
you know,
I got into it,
I read a little bed and I was like,
hm,
probably some good principles in here,
some decent ideas.
And I always associated scientologists
with being positive people that got a
lot of things done.
That's a very true statement and I'm
telling you at what they call the bottom
of the bridge because the entire
scientology experience would be a bridge
to total freedom.
You went to reading at a certain point,
you're given basic things,
basic courses,
basic communication skills that you're
taught.
And I'm telling you,
you go out on the street after you do
this stuff and you're more effective in
handling life.
So the early stages of it,
you feel I need it.
They're very effective.
I mean they were effective then they're
effective today.
If you'll learn the proper communication
formula that will improve your life
alone.
Sure.
Just communicating correctly,
knowing there's component,
there's parts of it.
It's not just,
hey,
you and the other guy says,
what do you want?
You know,
there's literally get the other person's
attention.
Make sure you're giving them a
communication that he can understand.
You're not going to talk that somebody
in French if he's English,
you know,
just all little details that you learn
and you drilled these.
And then there's other things about,
uh,
interpersonal relationships with your
wife or a group you'll learn to.
You're better off.
So they're essentially telling you how
to be a better person in the beginning.
Yes.
And part of that you would then also
become more positive just simply by
having this,
these skills.
Well this sounds good.
It is good.
Where does it go bad?
Well,
here's where it goes bad.
Look,
the further on you get in the.
Let me back up a second.
Let's say you learn the component parts
of communication and you say,
Hey,
you know what?
This is good shit,
right?
You agree to that.
That's the first step on taking you on
this entire journey and then you may be
a learn how you can divide your business
into seven parts so that you could
monitor various parts of it or your life
in the seven parts so you could manage a
how you're doing income wise,
how education is your public relations.
These are all things you can easily
agree to show.
Not a little later on there's a data or
a fact introduced that doesn't quite
make sense to you,
but you think,
you know what?
Everything they told me it was good so
far.
I'm just going to accept this now you're
on the road.
Give me an example.
I'm like,
is it like Xenu type shit?
Well,
yeah.
That would be a big example,
but the way down the line,
right?
That's way down the line,
but there's.
There's some early wackiness that gives
you an indication that things might to
something.
You know?
I think you're right.
I think that's the one where you've
agreed to so many things so far and all
of the auditing you've gotten that
that's helped you when it comes to that.
As an example,
when I got on that level,
I thought,
well,
wait a minute.
There's $150.
Billion People on 76 nearby planets,
and they brought them here in spaceships
have,
fuck did to get everybody here.
I looked at it from a physical point of
view from a point of view of logistics.
It's a lot of spaceships,
but I thought,
well,
I'll accept it.
I'll just do it.
One hundred and 50 billion people per
planet.
That was the problem was overpopulation,
but do you see what I'm saying?
So at that point you've agreed to so
many things that were.
Right,
right.
I understand it comes up to that.
You're not going to say,
hey,
you're out of your goddamn mind.
It's helping you give you a direction in
life.
It's making you more positive.
It's giving you better communication
skills.
You have a structure that you could
fall.
When you communicate with people,
it makes you more presentable.
So everything's good in the beginning.
Yeah.
Why doesn't somebody just take that part
and just like get rid of the rest?
Listen,
I tell in my book what we're looking at
right here,
you know,
rootless scientology,
my son David miscavige and me I say at
the very end if they would,
if they were to just to stick to the
beginning things,
number one and number two have a general
amnesty where they forgive everybody who
they think has tried to determine the
shit's gonna hit the fan,
but maybe at the end of it you'd get
some people back and knock off the
disconnection policy.
I think if they did that,
it could be one of the best self help
groups ever.
But once you get up into those upper
levels where they tell you you're going
to become superhuman as an example,
you will be able to,
as a spiritual being,
leave your body and go some other place
as an example.
And read a newspaper in Germany.
Huh?
That it's not like remote viewing.
Yes.
And I'm going to tell you,
Joe,
I was involved for 42 years.
He never went to Germany,
no,
never learned about in Portugal,
but you know,
like a fucking,
you know,
seriously though I never met one person
that has ever achieved that.
Nor did I achieve it.
But you don't talk about it.
I understand.
One of the things that say you don't
talk about your case to somebody else,
so that's compartmentalized.
So everybody who's done this,
his thinking and I never got it when
maybe I'm the only one,
right?
So like maybe if I just keep working at
this one day,
I'm gonna pop through.
That's exactly when you go for the next
slide today,
explain how you're going to do that as
through meditation techniques.
Is it through some sort of hypnosis?
Like how,
how are they supposed to go to Germany
and read newspaper?
Well out of their body,
there's drills that you,
that you,
they have you do like in the earlier
what they call ot levels,
operating Phaeton Phaeton his award they
use for spiritual being,
and one of the drills that you would do
would be spot three objects outside of
your body spot.
Three objects inside your body spot,
three objects out,
judge your body spot,
three objects inside your body on a
repetitive basis and that's supposed to
let you out.
So is that an example?
So it's like a meditation.
So I guess it would be a spot.
Are you saying like envision?
Well,
I mean in the physical universe you
spots like that Clark,
this book,
and then inside your body just think
about three blocks from and lungs and
ribs.
Yeah.
Okay.
But then the other thing is like when
you get to ot three and you're talking
about body,
Satan's.
These are the alien beings that were
brought here,
put on a nearby volcano,
a hydrogen bomb would shut off and they
sent it for,
grabbed these people liquid.
You can look on the Internet and find
it.
I've read it all unfortunately.
And what happens then is they are all
latched to your body like a bunch of
fleas damage and they're affecting your,
your thinking and your personality.
And the ID on these upper levels is to
get rid of all of them and achieved
this.
Nobody's ever done it.
Like if there were three people who did
it,
I'd say,
Hey,
you know,
maybe it can be right.
Not,
not a fucking one.
Excuse my French buddy.
No,
you can swear away.
Okay,
listen,
I got my doctorate degree and swearing
in the United States Marine Corps.
But you know,
so how did you go from that to this?
How do you go from the Marine Corps,
which is about as real as it gets to
this?
Well,
you just looking to improve yourself.
Yes.
I was always look,
listen,
as a little kid in mountain carnival,
Pennsylvania where I was born and
raised,
I used to go up in our Garrett or the
attic,
whatever you wanna call it and my dad
had all these books there and I usually
take books off the shelf and read them
and try to find out about life.
I was always looking for something and
I'm always looking to improve myself or
find a better way to live.
And I had a friend back in the sixties.
I'm Nelson Sandy.
I'm a musician too.
I don't know whether you knew that.
No,
I didn't.
Yeah,
I played professionally my whole life,
Nelson,
Sandy,
and also been in the sales business
because I had four kids and you know,
you gotta pay the bills no matter what
you do.
So Nelson was a friend of mine and sales
in one day he set them,
we run,
how would you like to make an extra
$100,000
a year?
So what the hell,
you know?
Great.
So he introduced me to something called
holiday magic.
That's a marketing scheme,
you know what I mean by that,
right?
Yeah.
So what scheme pyramid scheme right here
made.
Yeah.
So I went to an opportunity meeting and
I thought,
you know,
maybe I could do this.
So I bought in and I started doing it in
one day.
We're at an opportunity meeting that we
were running and there's a girl standing
next to me talking to a guy over here
and I'm talking to this guy.
This guy says I'm a scientologist,
I just hang on a second.
What is that?
I pinned him down for about a half an
hour and for whatever reason the name
rang a bell.
So he told me that I could go visit
somebody who was a scientologist and
they discuss it one day a week guy,
the name of Frank Ogle in Woodbury,
New Jersey.
By the way,
you're from North Jersey,
don't you?
Yeah,
Newark,
yeah.
Okay.
So I go to this place and he would have
little classes where he talk about
communication and various things.
I went there for about four days in a
month,
like for a month,
one day a week,
and I thought,
okay,
I got it now.
Motor factor here.
David,
when he was born,
he was cursed with an asthma condition.
That was the bane of his existence.
I mean as a little baby sometimes he
turned blue.
He couldn't read out and it was horrible
to watch this.
And I was the one who took care of that
just about totally.
As matter of fact,
when he would have these attacks,
I would take him to a pediatrician in
Burlington,
New Jersey called Dr Ziegler.
He'd give them a shot of adrenaline and
I knew that given a little kid a shot of
adrenaline was not great.
Okay.
So I would try all kinds.
They didn't,
they didn't have inhalers back then they
had inhalers,
but that's handling the symptom,
not the cause.
And I didn't know what to do to handle
the cause I to the new shit.
Like one winter he's just in a full
blown attack,
turning blue.
It's cold jersey,
you know,
gold.
Jersey winter.
I took them upstairs to the bathroom,
took off his clothes,
stuck off mine,
stood in the shower,
said David,
I'm not punishing man.
I'm with you.
I had the warm water on it,
turned it off.
That water is that coming out of there
about 34 degrees.
He started breathing,
kicked it,
wiped them down with a Turkish towel
that handled it for the moment.
I used to do shit like that.
Anything to handle them.
So now I found out about scientology
from this Nelson,
sandy and Frank Ogle was the guy.
I took David Down one day and I said,
is there anything you can do for David?
Would Scientology Auditing,
which is basically another word for
counseling.
He took David in and 45 minutes later
dave comes out.
Isaiah was a gun and he says,
Dad,
I'm handled,
and he never had another severe attack
and his entire youth,
he had some possible with communication,
with communication,
you can stop asthma.
You come to the point where you have a
realization maybe where it started or
how you could be contributing to it or
maybe where it starts kicking in old.
Was He when you brought them in there?
I guess this was using about nine years
old.
Wow.
Okay.
So like what?
What tools did they use to help him kick
asthma?
That communication,
that just communication like,
hi,
what's,
what's going on?
He got asthma.
What communication do you mean by
communication?
Okay.
He did you use what's called the
creative processing,
which is something that they used to use
and what it is is you figure out how you
could be contributing to that and then
you do a mental image picture of
something that you think you're doing to
contribute to that and back and forth.
It's a little for me to try to explain
it in a little session like this.
It's a little hard because.
Well,
it's a little hard to understand,
but if it did work on him,
so you're saying in some sense asthma
may be psychosomatic and maybe in your
head for him it was to that degree.
Yes,
I am saying never got asthma again.
He never had a severe attack again.
He had my minor attacks,
but he was able to stop them with these.
He used to get so bad that it would
debilitate them.
I mean,
he was out of school for a week one time
with an attack.
This is before we,
I ever took him to see Frank Ogle and
um,
that impressed me.
The fact that this handle that for the
moment.
Anyway,
so with that and some other things,
I decided I'm going to get my whole
family and scientology because it look
his whole life.
That was a problem for me to handle and
this,
at least at that moment,
got into the point where he was like in
charge of it.
It didn't happen to them again.
That severe.
Does that make sense?
It doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
So that's what persuaded you to begin
quite a bit.
So everything was good for awhile.
Right.
I got in.
I'll tell you how good it was.
I got in and my whole family got in.
I decided to take my whole family to
England and in 1972 I moved there for a
year and three months and it had the
whole family studies scientology in
England.
Yeah.
And then came back for a little while
and went over again in 1974 a study more
scientology when I was there that time I
got a recording deal with the polydore
company solo album and I got a writer's
contract with the chapels publishing and
I got asked to plan BBC to all is in a
book.
By the way,
I'll give you the details.
This was all while l Ron Hubbard was
alive while he was alive.
And you meet him.
Never met him.
No.
But your son did listen to my son joined
the sea organization when he was 16
years old.
Within seven months he was working with
l,
Ron Hubbard.
What is this?
The sea organization is explaining that
to people.
Okay.
There are several different ways that
you could do scientology.
The number one way would be as if you're
a public person and you just go into an
organization there called orgs.
You go in and you buy services,
but you live in the outside world.
You have a job,
you have a home,
you know all these things,
but you pay for a service.
That's number one.
Another level would be that you worked
for an organization and you could sign a
two and a half year or a five year
contract to work there and you get to a
billion year contracts to,
well now what you're getting ahead of
it.
That's public,
that,
that's working for an organization on
the level of a two and a half or five
year contract.
The last step would be the sea
organization.
There you sign billion year contract.
In other words,
you're signing away your future lives to
get this scientology disseminated.
Um,
has anybody ever challenged one of those
billion year contracts?
Like what does it mean?
Like do you listen to you?
You're getting the skinny and as hard as
this is to believe,
once you're in it for awhile and you see
that this is helping you and maybe your
family,
the point of is that they want to get
this disseminated to every man,
woman,
and child on the planet and improve life
for everybody.
So it's like you're on this crusade to
get it disseminated.
So they believe they're doing this to
help people.
Yes.
It all sounds good,
right?
All sounds good in the beginning.
Well,
it reads better than the lips.
It's not that way at all.
What will,
how is it?
How is it?
I'll tell you these days right now,
like,
sure.
They get people to donate money to
what's called the International
Association of scientologists or donate
money to build an organization,
build a new church someplace and it give
you a piece of paper and commend you.
You know,
it's a nice business,
low overhead,
you know,
so you give them money,
they give you paper,
they gave you a commendation or saying
you're the devil,
right?
You're,
you're,
you've achieved.
The thing is,
look,
they've opened a lot of new buildings,
but Joe,
there's not people in air.
There's air,
okay,
but they say we're expanding.
They're expanding the real estate
interest,
but they're not expanding.
The number of people in scientology was
a,
well,
if you go on the Internet,
you can find out all the abuses they've
done,
like people going bankrupt because they
had to contribute so much money that you
get a second and third mortgage on her
house,
give it to the church.
They can't afford it after they've
declared bankruptcy.
People being disconnected from their
families.
That.
Let's talk about that.
Bill.
I want to go back to the sea org thing
for a second,
but then let's talk about that.
Yeah,
so the sea org thing is your son joins
the sea org when he's 16 years old.
Here's what happened.
I came home from work one day and he's
laying on his in his room on his bed,
kind of like that with his head in his
hands as they day.
What's up man?
He says,
Daddy,
I don't want to go to school anymore is
why not?
He said,
listen,
all the kids are taking drugs,
they just,
they don't show the teachers any
respect.
They're not willing to learn anything I
want.
I want to join this year.
I want to help l Ron Hubbard because by
this time we've been to England twice.
He's trained to be an auditor.
An auditor is a person who applies this
technology of scientology in auditing or
counseling.
Okay.
And he said,
this is what I want to do.
I thought to myself,
he's 15,
he's going to be 16.
Shortly after that.
Look,
when I was 17,
I joined the marines.
My Dad had assigned for me because I was
only 17 and it probably was one of the
best moves I ever made.
I mean,
the first night in bootcamp,
I said to myself,
this is the worst fucking mistake ever
made in my life.
At that moment,
12 weeks later,
I said to myself,
I can make myself do anything,
and in that 12 weeks it turned me from
an undisciplined civilian into a
discipline marine and I've utilized
that.
My whole life has helped me always.
I kind of looked at that and I thought,
well,
I was 17,
maybe it looked like I didn't know what
the hell I was doing,
but I come out of winter and if David
wants to do this and what is he going to
get out of going to school and he has no
desire to do anything else.
I said,
okay,
I'll help you.
So that was it.
So when he was 16,
the next day we put them on a plane.
He went down to the flag land base in
Florida and they say,
well then I think it was seven or eight
months,
he was working right with l Ron Hubbard,
fornia the sea org.
Like,
is it a boat you're actually on a boat?
No,
the sea organization is a term used
because in 1967,
ron started what he called the sea
project where he bought these,
the ship and invited people to come with
him to contribute to this project saying
that his research could be done better
away from land masses.
I mean,
in fact the law was after him,
you know that,
right?
It was a tax thing,
Yeah,
I mean they,
they were trying to snag them and when
you're out out in international waters,
they can serve you a subpoena,
but it was such an adventure story.
Right.
And people look over,
look at plus to get to where it
captain's outfit.
No,
not everybody.
He goes,
Oh yeah,
admiral.
He give himself metals l,
Ron Hubbard.
Yeah.
You know,
I never saw that.
All I saw was that he was considered the
commodore,
but you remember the Peace Corps?
Yes.
All right.
That was an adventure and people would
go on our,
but they actually were doing something.
Now.
What was the sea org doing?
Well,
the CEO was on this ship and they'd have
people come there for advanced level
services,
get that and uh,
they would send missions out to various
organizations to correct any out indices
in the way maybe they were delivering
the technology or,
or fix something that was going wrong.
It was run like a military organization.
And then the sea org went ashore and
they established the flag land base in
clearwater,
Florida.
So that is still referred to as flag.
Yet,
when El Rey to Lr and Hubbard had the
ships that was going to consider the
flagship.
Okay.
Am I filling you in an definition?
So he joined that.
He ascended through the ranks.
He's working with l,
Ron Hubbard,
and slowly.
You guys get disconnected.
Is that what happens?
No,
as matter of fact,
when he was doing that,
we were still in very good communication
with each other like I'm telling you
something.
We had a lot of great times together
when he was growing up.
It no two ways about it and I can't say
that it was like bad relationship in any
way.
There was a guy by the name of Lord
Acton.
He was a Britisher.
He was a member of parliament.
He lived from 1834 to early 19 hundreds.
He's the one that made the observation.
Power tends to corrupt and absolute
power corrupts.
Absolutely,
and I think this is what happened to
David,
that when l Ron Hubbard died,
he saw a chance to move up and you got
people out of the way who didn't want to
cooperate.
Him Put people on various posts that
would cooperate with them and he took
over the ownership and the leadership of
scientology and what contributed to that
was an incident where he had a severe
asthmatic attack and they had to take
him to the emergency room of a hospital.
Paul Grady's a guy that took him there
and when Paul pick them up after they
did the stuff that the handle him,
he was okay.
They would set the Paul.
Listen,
I had a great realization when I was
there and it's this power is not
granted.
It is assumed.
So he assumed the leadership of
scientology and heroes right to the top.
That's how that happened.
So how did you get disconnected from
them?
Well,
look,
there was an event that he had none of
the event.
There's something that he did,
which he'll always be admired for.
He got actually got the Church of
scientology tax exemption.
Alright.
He literally got the irs to grant the
fact that this is a church you have now
a tax exemption.
People contribute to it,
can you deduct it?
That was a very,
very big win that then gave him power.
Okay.
I decided to join this organization in
1985.
I wanted to contribute to doing whatever
I could to help him.
I joined the Sea Organization and I'm at
the Hamate base,
you know,
I'm coming out of the music studio
because since I was a musician,
I worked in the music studio and we did
films.
I'd composed music for various technical
films we had or public relations films
and I walked out of the studio one day
and I saw him a little distance off the
left with an entourage and I yelled out,
hey dave.
And he turned around and he looked at me
and I'm telling you,
Joe,
he gave me a look that I thought I
better never do that again.
On that base I was then a staff member.
The fact that I was biologically his
father and in fact his father,
he,
he referred to me as Ron when he spoke
to me.
When he sent me a gift for my birthday
or Christmas or something.
He always had their dad,
but that was the beginning.
Now with further on down the road we got
the more it became,
I used to have to call him after a
while.
Okay.
It became more and more me,
Ron Miscavige,
the staff member,
and David is the leader of the church.
Once they started implementing the rules
at the base where you couldn't send a
letter,
I without being checked where you
surrounded with barb wire pointing and
pointing out you couldn't talk on the
telephone without having somebody
listen.
You couldn't drive off on your own to go
to a store to get a fucking pair of
underwear.
You had to order it on the Internet.
If you got on the Internet,
there was a filter on it.
Were anything about miscavige for
scientology?
Come up,
you'd be blocked.
So now I'm living a sequestered life.
Waking up in the morning,
going to breakfast at 9:00,
9:30.
Having a muster,
you know to muster is no.
Okay?
You line up your account for everybody.
Alright?
Twelve o'clock,
go to lunch.
12 30 lineup for another muster.
Go to work in the afternoon,
5:00,
go to dinner,
5:30,
go to another muster.
And then work the rest of the night,
or sometimes 9:30
or 10:00,
have another muster.
That was my life seven days a week,
except on Saturday.
You'd work on the grounds to beautify
the base.
Doesn't sound good time,
Ron.
It's a great existence.
Joe,
how would you like to live that way?
That doesn't sound good.
It wasn't good.
Stuck.
Well,
here's the thing.
There were enough times when I did
things that were good,
like we would do an album and it was a
matter of fact.
Here's something that we didn't.
I first got in and there was a book that
came out called mission earth that l Ron
Hubbard wrote Edgar.
When you remember Edgar Winter Know
Edgar Winter.
Johnny winters brother?
Yes.
She musician the musician.
The Rock Guy?
Yeah.
Okay.
Edgar came to the base and we did an
album.
I played on the album with him.
Edgar winter just scientology was.
He probably still is.
Wow.
One of them's dead,
right?
John said Johnny's dead.
But Edgar,
I mean he was.
You have no idea how good he is until
you see them operating a studio.
Anyway,
I played the trumpet parts on the album,
I played solos and some of this stuff,
the album,
that was what I did and it was great
time.
Bust your ass working,
but that's a good time,
right Isaac Hayes.
I used to do gigs with him,
you know,
chase's great guy and those,
those were fun times.
There were other things that we did that
turned out good,
but then there's time in between where
you're working sometimes days on end
with when the okay a couple of days,
no sleep,
working your ass off and if you screwed
up it was hell to pay and kind of work
is being done.
What does all the work.
Okay.
I'll give you an example.
There's about six major events that are
done by the church every year.
There's the a.
In new years there's a major event.
Okay.
And then in March you have l,
Ron Hubbard birthday and then in May you
have dianetics.
Alright guys,
what do you guys do for Ellen's
birthday?
Well,
there would be any event where you would
show him in various aspects of life,
improving life in some aspect and we'd
have a video on that and we would have
to write music for that.
A city would have to shoot the pictures
or take old pictures and produce these,
edit them.
We do music for it and we'd have a
product to.
I had an event when David's the one
event,
they could present this for when the
anniversary of dianetics modern science
of mental health.
That was another event.
Okay,
and then in your preparing for events,
essentially all the time it was when
you'd end one,
you'd have start the next one in June
you have the anniversary of the maiden
voyage.
That was something we did every year and
then there's auditor's Day in August.
All right,
and then there's the international
association of Scientology Event in
October.
So all this time you're just constantly
working.
You're never hanging out with your son.
You don't.
You don't have any quality time
together.
Sometimes he would come to the base for
two months and wouldn't even give me a
phone call.
Look,
Joe,
you got to understand,
I wish the fuck this didn't turn out
this way.
Okay.
Just straight up.
So I will feel responsible in any way
for bringing them in.
Well,
everybody deals with life the way they
deal with it.
My other son isn't that way in my
daughters aren't that way,
but it is your other son.
Scientology as well.
He's on a scientology now.
Did he quit with you?
He quit earlier than me.
And what about your daughters?
They're in.
They're in,
yes.
And if they were connected from them,
they're disconnected from me.
Right.
You're not allowed to.
They're not allowed to talk to you.
Here's what happens though.
If they were to talk to me,
they're friends would disconnect from
them.
If you have a job with the scientology
employer and they found out that you
talked to me,
he would get fired that day.
It's insidious.
It spreads out the penalty for talking
to what's called a suppressive person,
which would be me like real life prick.
As an example,
when I was 70 years old,
David and my two daughters bought me a
car.
Okay.
A car,
when I was 75 years old,
my daughter sent me 75 gifts.
Now I left.
Now I'm the worst father who's ever
lived.
I'm a slimeball.
They character assassinate me and their
hate sites.
They would give a card to somebody who
was that bad.
Oh,
we made a mistake.
He really was a prick.
All the along.
It doesn't make sense,
so if you're trying to make sense out of
it,
it doesn't make sense.
But this is built into the policy of
scientology.
Anybody who leaves could be in says
anything about the church could be
considered to be a suppressive person.
And was this always the case or is this
Polish exacerbated?
Well,
l Ron Hubbard wrote the policies while
he was alive.
He also wrote more fiction than anybody
that's ever lived.
Yeah.
Does everybody know that inside the
church?
Uh,
they probably do.
Yeah.
But didn't they?
Does anybody make that connection?
No.
The guy wrote more fake shit than any
person that's ever walked the face of
the earth.
But he also had the time to talk to the
aliens to get all this data.
Yeah.
To write this real stuff that is just,
that is a,
that's,
that's a suspension of disbelief that
defies logic.
Well,
as fries defies understanding,
as you said earlier,
just need to get to a higher otc.
What is it that it Ota level.
Operating level.
Okay.
But you got to understand most people
who do it don't have rocks in your head.
They're not nuts.
They're not stupid.
People know I've talked.
I had a neighbor who was a
scientologist,
a very nice guy.
Yeah.
And he sort of fit that bill that I was
talking to get it earlier,
but he fit that bill that I was talking
about earlier where he's a guy that's
always improving himself.
He was healthy exercise dbs.
Well captiva was a nice neighbor.
It was a good guy.
And uh,
you know,
I was like,
all right.
I,
I sort of looked into scientology after
I became friends with him,
you know,
I mean,
I got the book early on,
like I said,
but I never really did anything other
than read the book.
I never looked into.
This is before the Internet,
you know,
the internet sort of exposed all this
stuff.
So that was the end of it.
That literal use literally and tall.
And how much has it dropped off since
then?
Well,
it's been estimated by people who would
know that there's maybe 20,000
scientologists right now.
What was it at its peak?
I think it was in the early 90
[inaudible].
About 100,000.
Wow.
Yeah,
20,000.
That's like a,
a good Louis ck concert.
Well,
the thing is most people I get that
international base are people who have
been around for 25,
30,
35,
40 years.
And you think,
okay,
how could you live this way?
Look,
most people are not going to do what I
do.
I was [inaudible] 76 years old when I
left.
Okay.
And you were 75 when they gave you 75
gifts.
So you like this?
Not Enough.
I've got to get the fuck out of here.
I need.
No,
you mean not enough gifts?
I didn't get in [inaudible] 76.
Right.
Listen,
I always did.
Well actually I'll tell you something
that happened and I brought this just to
show you and you'll have a little.
What is that?
Kindle.
Okay.
Are you allowed to have those in there?
No.
Really,
you can't have a kindle and I didn't
know why.
I didn't know why.
What happened is David gave me this
Kendall and the security guards were
doing.
They're not trying to get it away from
me,
but they wouldn't come and strong army
because David is the man.
So David gave it to you in the security
guards are trying to take it away from
you.
Why?
Okay.
I didn't know.
Did you tell them?
It was loaded up with l Ron Hubbard
books where it was.
It was just fiction books that he put in
your family field earth?
No,
not battlefield or northern Michigan
missionary,
but the other earlier fiction,
which I thought was pretty interesting,
but anyway,
they're trying to get the says,
Hey,
fuck you man.
Dave gave me.
This is mine,
you know?
Oh,
okay.
Rhonda did back off.
Now,
one day I'm reading something and
there's a feature on here where you see
this is the camera on that?
No.
Okay.
You see this little
switch that goes this way,
this way up,
down and in.
So if you got a word that you'd like to
look up and get the meaning of,
you'd go to the library or not the
library,
the dictionary,
and you'd select the award and pressure
to the right and it would say search
store.
I accidentally held it a little bit too
long and it went right past search store
to google.
I was on the Internet.
Will no filter with your kindle,
my kindle.
I.
What the fuck is this even know about
the Google back then I knew about the
google,
but there was filter on a computer.
Go through it with.
There's no filter on this.
That's why the security guards were
trying to get it,
but they wouldn't tell me that.
Obviously they're not going to say,
well,
there's no filter so you can get on the
Internet.
I mean these guys weren't that swift.
There aren't the sharpest knives in the
drawer,
but.
But how did they know that?
How they know about that?
They're the ones who,
if you get a computer that you give it
to them,
they put a filter on it and then I give
it back to you.
Okay.
So they just know they've got some
techno geeks do.
I don't know how to do that shit,
but they had never done that to the
kindle.
But they wanted to go.
They wanted to take it away from me.
Straight up googling stuff with your
kindle.
I looked at Google now,
uh,
the first time I've told that story
about Joseph an exclusive UNICO.
Excited.
Yeah.
Well,
I'll tell you one of the things I looked
at as like l Ron Hubbard's war record.
He was not a hero.
You didn't have two purple hearts.
He's fucking made up story.
And there was a girl named Annie Tillman
who was with l Ron Hubbard when he died.
And tinman was a messenger with l Ron
Hubbard since she was a little girl and
she was with him when he actually died.
So Annie was a long term loyal
scientologists.
She's at the base where I lived in
Hamilton and she got lung cancer,
so they sent her to Los Angeles to get
care and they sent a girl down to be
like a personal servant to take care of
her needs,
so she'd be okay.
So occasionally I would say to Martin
who was the medical liaison officer.
In other words,
she took care of our health and she'd
have us go to the doctors and stuff.
I said,
Martin,
how's Andy Doing?
Ohhh,
Ronnie.
She's doing a great.
Yeah.
Okay,
good.
I'm on a kindle.
She died six months earlier,
never told anybody innovation.
Now we're living in these apartments on
the base.
Is it?
Several days later and there was a
building called the laundry room where
you took your clothes to get cleaned and
pressed.
You picked up sheets,
little Amenia ds like that and there's
two girls outside the laundry room and
he said,
Ronnie,
would you want to chip in for a birthday
present for Annie?
I said,
Nah,
I'm gonna Patch on it now.
Had Jesus Christ.
They either know and they're keeping up
the ruse or they don't know and they're
being used as she was shields to make
sure,
make sure people think she's still
alive.
Right.
Well,
that was a major thing for me.
I then started to think I gotta get
Outta here.
Mind you.
I thought earlier things were starting
to go south and we would have.
I give you an example.
Here's what happened.
We're on the ship and we're playing for
a show at one of these maiden voyages
anniversary things and we have a guy
there who is not a rap artist,
but he's like a beat box,
you know,
he uses voice like that,
so now doug is up there and then you
start saying,
you know,
he says,
I'll tell you,
my kid was picked up by the cops
yesterday day,
but he's not really a bad kid.
You know,
he's hanging out with the wrong guys and
blah,
blah blah.
And these are all saying the shit that
you don't say to this exclusive
audience.
David hears that to handle this.
Me and the rest of the band were sent to
work in the bilge on the ship
because he fucked up.
We paid the price.
What I should've done was kicked into
band because I was directing the band,
kicked into band and start playing music
and drowned them out.
You're going to build the temperature
down there is between $125.
One hundred and 30 degrees.
I'm in my sixties.
Doesn't matter.
Shit like that would go on.
So when things like that,
what happened at that?
Man,
we can't live this way,
but my wife Becky,
she is an eternal optimist.
She would always say run.
It's gonna.
Get better.
It can't keep on going this way.
And I'd say becky listening because she
a boulder rolling down a mountain that
boulder is not going to stop and start
rolling up.
It's going to get worse.
If things are going bad,
they have a tendency to continue going
bad.
It's just fantastic to me that you found
out all this information on Google.
Yeah.
And that you were shielded from all this
stuff.
Yeah.
That's.
That's the craziest part.
And you,
you were 75 at the time,
somewhere in that ruined our vision at
them.
I think it was two years later that we
actually escaped.
So how did you escape?
Well,
first of all,
I used to run the music department and
when I say run it and I'd make sure that
we did all the jobs were supposed to do
and I would compose music.
I worked with a guy by the name of Peter
[inaudible] and uh,
we,
we had some nice shit that we did
together.
So at this point you'd been in for how
many years?
Forty years?
No.
Industry Organization over 20 some
years.
Twenty something years in the sea
organization.
All in all.
Scientology.
Much more than that.
Yeah.
Well I was in scientology for 42 years.
This is your only source of income?
Yeah,
it's 50.
Well,
to begin with,
when I got in,
we got 30 bucks a week.
And then journalists.
What's that generous?
When it went up to 15 year olds,
when you got paid,
when you get paid,
sometimes you'd go for months without
getting paid at all.
Now the downside of that is you ain't
paying much into social security,
so if you leave like some of these
people will leave.
They got shit for social security.
They may have no,
no place to go,
no marketable skill,
a no car,
what are they going to do?
Right.
So that,
you know,
people say will stay.
They stay,
they gutted out.
And that's the position that you were
in.
What?
What made you decide,
okay,
well just to Google information.
No,
no,
no.
It was the treatment,
the way people were being treated and
some of the shit that went down like so
you would have been okay if they treated
you well and you still found out that a
woman had been dead for six months,
that l Ron Hubbard wasn't really a
warning,
but I'll tell you why.
If they had been actually disseminating
this information and people on this
planet,
we're doing better and life was becoming
better for large numbers of people.
I don't know if I still might be there
in other words.
So you could tell he was really being
effective in doing what you thought it
was supposed to do.
Precisely which has helped humanity.
Precisely.
Do you think that at the core that its
potential to help humanity is still
there?
You think that like,
like you were saying,
that the beginning stages of scientology
are beneficial and there was something
like if they got all these beneficial
things.
Yeah.
And just offer those,
the odds of that happening.
The odds now we're talking about would
be the same odds as me turning into a
penguin right now.
It's not likely to act.
So likely.
Not very likely.
Maybe you know,
and your son,
he's going to be running it forever.
Does he?
Is there is absolutely nobody was gonna
take over.
Is it election like fucking election
needs?
He runs it and that's the end of it.
He's surrounded by people,
I guess you'd call them psycho fencers.
Sycophants took offense.
Yeah.
Who just pump him up all the time and if
he says,
you know what,
I would like to have such and such.
Maybe he might want a different car.
Go,
go out and get it from one of those
people like what are the people like the
surround him that enabled him to
maintain this power.
They feel that he's a power source and
they support him a power because he's
the.
He runs the organization will.
Yeah,
because he got his tax exemption a.
he'll do things.
He's tough.
He's.
He's actually.
David is a very smart guy.
If it weren't for this streak in him
where he obtained all this power and had
this shit going on in scientology,
who knows?
I think you could been successful at
anything.
I believe that as well.
I think anybody who gets to.
I mean it's really unfortunate,
but it gets to any even a position of
being like a drug kingpin.
Pablo Escobar,
I'm sure he could have been successful
at other things here.
I decided to focus his mind in that
direction here.
Exactly right.
And that's how I feel.
So you feel like your son just fucked up
in getting on a path that is in your
eyes illegitimate versus you know,
him being the CEO of ibm or something
like that.
You could say that you could say that
and I'll tell you,
I think it would be.
You would be correct not.
I think you would be.
Does it?
Have you ever talked to him about
scientology that you.
You don't bring it up.
No.
I mean,
look,
take anybody with that much power.
Do you think you can sit down and say,
now look what I think is what the fuck
you talking to me about.
I'm running his fucking show and that if
it's your dad,
I think I would think you would just sit
down and have that line with him.
I'm telling you,
no.
Listen,
if you're a scientologist and you were
at that level,
you are of the belief that no spiritual
being is another spiritual beings,
mother or father or daughter or sister.
You happen to be occupying a body that
maybe was given to you by another
person,
but in your heart you're actually an
independent thinking life unit.
An immortal one to boot.
Okay.
Right.
Okay,
but let me ask you this.
Do people really believed that or do
they just kind of go along with it
because everybody else is going along
with it as it deserving?
Is there ever a time where you're alone
with somebody else's sea org?
Maybe you're setting up some video or
something like that and someone goes,
hey man,
this shit on the up and up.
Very seldom.
Very seldom,
but what I'll tell you why though?
The walls have ears.
Fuck No.
Well,
you're telling this to somebody.
They might write a knowledge report on
you,
a knowledge report while you're in deep
shit and okay.
Jamie Dimon right into knowledge.
Now,
as soon as we leave here.
Okay,
listen.
Okay.
I might laugh,
but boy,
when it's happened,
listen,
I'm sure,
and if it's found out later that he said
this to you and you didn't write a
knowledge report,
you are as culpable as he is for Shane
and what happens to you?
Somebody writes a knowledge one for
interrogation.
Oh,
what do they do it talk to.
I see you down in a meter.
Tells you why your crimes.
Wha.
What?
What evil purpose do you have to word
David?
What evil purpose you have to El Ron
Hubbard.
What thoughts have you had about
leaving?
destroying the organization?
Anything of a harmful nature?
They say,
man,
fuck this place.
What dee?
Dee.
Did they kick you out?
No.
So how's that work?
What if?
What if you get there?
What if someone writes a knowledge
report and you go,
you know what man?
I been thinking I got on Google.
I started reading a bunch of stuff.
I think it's all bullshit.
I don't even want to be here anymore,
man.
And Fuck,
fuck all this working for 50 bucks a
week.
This is stupid.
I don't want to do this anymore.
Why are we all doing this?
Why don't we just take the beginning
parts of this and just get rid of all
the stupid shit about separating from
your children and make this thing
better.
What do you say?
What would they do to you?
Well,
first of all,
you wouldn't dare do that if you were at
a place like I was at the international
base.
Okay.
Which is Golden Arrow productions in
Hemet,
California.
Why?
What would they do to you?
They'd sees you and then went out and
you'd be sequestered from the rest of
the group,
put it into a place where you weren't
associated with the rest of the group.
You'd go to lunch at a different time.
You'd have a security guard watching you
morning,
afternoon,
and night,
and you can never leave.
So I tried somebody to be like,
what if.
What if you say,
I just want to go home.
I want to get out of here.
I want to go get an apartment to do it,
man.
You just can't do it.
So they would just keep you at
physically like,
hold on,
hold you gotta,
chill,
chill.
And if the church,
well I'm sure they're going to hurt
dish,
but they can say,
oh,
ron could have left anytime.
You could.
That's bullshit.
That's complete bullshit.
If I would have been caught what I was
trying to leave,
which I'm going to get into,
I forget.
We were talking about,
okay,
if I would have been caught,
they would have taken me and becky
taking the keys to my car.
I would've been sequestered from her.
She'd been to Western for me.
We would have both been security checked
shit down with the hands on an emailer,
which I'm sure you know.
What is your.
I did one of those ones.
Okay.
I don't really think it works.
You don't think it works?
Sometimes it does.
Okay,
but that's not the point.
You'd sit down with that and be
interrogated and then you'd work maybe
four or five hours away.
It's a manual labor and when you weren't
doing that,
you'd be back on the.
On the cans again as they say,
what if you don't work?
What if you like,
fuck you.
I don't want to work like a difficult
bastard,
right?
Yeah.
Like what's ever happened?
What's that?
Has Anybody ever rebelled?
And it's human nature to rebel against
authority.
Yeah,
but certain amount of human nature to
to,
to come.
But when you're up at a place where you
have three or 400 people who feel
differently,
you're not that brave.
Does anybody ever have the gumption or
the notion to go,
hey,
what the fuck are we doing?
Does that ever happen?
Okay,
maybe we'll know what they do is they
escape like I did.
That's it.
They don't speak up for.
Right.
They know what they're in for.
Who the F here?
There was a guy named Alex.
he wanted a route out.
It took them four fucking years to route
out,
route out.
That's what they call it when that's the
proper way to leave where you sit down
and you do this routing form.
It's basically security checking.
You kill your,
you know,
for years.
Once you say if you sign a five year
contract.
Yeah,
we just said a five year contract.
You would be at an outer org there.
You just walk out of the fucking place
and people do that in outer org,
but you can't do that at the sea org.
Well not at you.
You could in Los Angeles,
but at the international base,
you're living in a compound.
You're surrounded.
Would barbwire,
pointing in and pointing out.
You're not going to jump that fence or
you'll really screw yourself style,
but if you say,
say if you sign a five year contract
when the fifth year's up,
you get to leave.
Yeah,
they're going to try to get you to re
enlist.
Okay.
But if you're at,
let's say you're working at one of the
organization Gianelli okay,
okay.
You can walk out in the street and say,
hey,
see you later.
What are they going to do?
Because you're,
you're in the free world.
You're in the free world.
You're not running world at the
international base.
I understand.
All right,
so you had to plot some sort of an out
so you to think about it and then you
had to work with the wife and you guys
had to like hush hush.
Right?
And you asked me what led to that.
Well,
there's one major thing that led to it
and that was this.
We got a new music director.
I didn't want to have the post anymore.
I was getting old and got this young guy
and I would write melodies all day,
all week months.
Every melody I ever wrote was rejected
by him and other words.
Everything I was doing was a piece of
shit,
but I couldn't quit.
So this new guy was not fun to work
with.
Terrible.
It was terrible.
And yet,
toes division,
I was the only one who had gotten a
recording contract on my own steam.
Nobody gave it to him.
I didn't have a rich daddy or a contract
with chapels publishing for my writing
and asked to play on the BBC.
Nobody had achieved that in that
department.
Now maybe my skills weren't up to how
the right modern music.
And I used to beg him.
I said,
listen,
what do you want as an acceptable
particle?
I'm a trained musician.
Uh,
let me give me some ideas what you want
and I'll start writing that.
Fuck you learn it.
Just like I did this.
I was treated well.
It doesn't sound like a fun time.
So she'll wait a minute.
Talk to your son and say,
Hey,
kid listens.
Fucking new guy sucks.
Wait a minute.
I did that.
I called him and I would assume I wrote
to him.
I said,
Dave,
you got to get together with me.
Right?
So we got together and said,
look,
I'm working all day long and nothing I'm
doing is being approved.
You got to get me a different job.
I says,
I don't care if you hit me a job washing
cars in multiple,
but I want to do something.
So at the end of the day you can say,
here's what he did.
Okay.
He says,
I'll look into it.
He never looked into it.
A couple months later,
I said,
Becky,
look,
we're getting the fuck out of here.
Then we started planning.
So what was your plan as far as like
getting a job because you had been
working there for 25 years?
Well,
I'm a,
I'm a good musician.
I'm not just a punk.
I mean I played quite a bit of jobs in
Milwaukee.
So you had skill and skills.
Good salesman too,
you know.
Um,
I also,
here's how I look.
Okay,
I'm 76 years old.
I'll want to spend them at rest of my
life suffering out everyday.
Fuck this shit.
I'm getting Outta here.
Right.
Got It.
And becky finally says,
okay.
And she saw the writing on the wall that
wasn't going to get better.
So now we don't want to leave and leave
everything behind because what little
possessions we had was what we had.
All right,
so we started,
by the way,
I mentioned a little earlier that my
daughter sent me 75 gifts gifts on 75th
birthday,
right?
Yeah.
Becky came up with the idea.
My mother is going to celebrate.
By the way,
my wife is younger than me.
My first wife,
I divorced him and married a much
younger woman,
so her mother is going to have her 70th
birthday.
So we decided to send her mother 70
gifts.
Now in order to do this,
it has to go to the security guards.
So we would send her like a detail and
kid for a car.
I mean her chances of detailing the car
as a gift were nil to none.
But they saw that,
okay,
we're sending her 70 gifts.
So it got through them.
We sent her center,
our l,
Ron Hubbard library books that we had
some of the things and we got a lot of
stuff out of there that I couldn't fit
in the car when we were going.
Uh,
you see what I'm saying?
Smart.
And then after all was said and done,
we got everything out of there.
We plotted it out and I did this on
Sunday mornings.
On Sunday mornings you had breakfast at
9:00.
Now we lived on the southern side of the
base and we lived in rooms.
You couldn't have a refrigerator,
you couldn't have a coffeemaker there.
But across the street on the north side,
I worked in the studio.
There was a refrigerator there and I
used to keep,
like Italian Salami may be super sad.
Uh,
some Parmesan cheese,
Romano cheese.
So early Sunday morning at 9:00.
And I planned this out because there's
two gates.
There's one main gate where there's a
security guard sitting in a booth and in
down the road about 200 yards,
there's another gate where there's a
little camera and they see you coming.
And they got used to me going across to
the north side to go to the studio and
I'd come back to the main gate and bring
the security guards a piece of cheese or
Salami.
So they thought a Sunday morning he's
going to get his goodies and that it
wasn't feeding the watchdogs.
This is set up,
right?
Right.
So it comes a day.
We're going to leave March 25th,
2012.
We get up real early and I had a little
notebook.
I must have checked it 20 times.
What I wanted to take,
what I wanted to leave behind like the
night before.
And by the way,
my biggest cover on being able to get
out of there was the fact that I was 76
years old and I was the father of the
chairman of the board.
Nobody would suspect that I was going to
leave unauthorized it like alright,
okay.
Shout them out with a mesh bag full of
shoes,
putting it in the car.
And one of the security guards come by
on his bicycle and Italian Guy Sal.
Hey Ronnie,
how are you doing that?
Good.
You know?
And he sees me putting this in,
but he justifies it in his mind.
He'll,
he's putting stuff in his car.
Doesn't think twice why it.
Of course another guy's coming by an old
time,
scientologist I have a bag of clothes
and putting in a car.
Ronnie.
How's it going?
Good deal.
Norm?
Yeah.
Alright.
You know,
put it in the car.
So we got through all that.
Okay.
So now Sunday morning,
9:00
we get in the car,
we're loaded up and we're driving down
to get to that.
Second Gate is about a half mile down
the road.
We go there and I'm going past our mess
hall where we would eat and this is
called Masco Canyon in or MCI.
It's where the crew would eat their
meals and I see the chase car like on
Sunday morning,
there's only two security guards on
duty.
One is in the main booth and the and the
other one is in a car so he can rove and
it's called the chase car.
Okay.
So the chase car is parked outside of
the mess hall.
I knew sal was in there.
So I go around another hundred yards
down the road,
get to the gate.
And by the way,
at this point in my heart is in my
throat.
All right.
Because if you,
when I hit that Buzzer,
if you're going to have said come up to
the boot,
that was it.
I was fucked.
Okay.
Hit the buzzer.
Didn't say anything to gate opens.
I pulled out of the gate.
This is becky returning left.
So I turned left jam to throttle and I
knew I had to make it them that he's.
There's three roads.
One goes to route 60,
straight ahead rather.
The other one goes to route 10 and if I
turn,
unless they go into Hamot I knew by the
time I'm going down a road and he would
be on trying to get me into next.
They'll run.
What the hell are you doing?
They need called sal and sal get up to
the booth pronto.
I know sal would have to run out,
get in the car.
I'd already be at those crossroads or
the tree roads.
So I knew in sal came,
he needed to turn right or go straight
ahead.
I turned left Winton to Hamot.
We hit the boondocks and I was free.
Wow.
So when did you do then?
We drove to Wisconsin.
To Jeff money on you?
Yeah,
I had money on me and I paid for.
I paid for everything.
Cash.
Joe,
you only get 50 bucks a week.
How long did you save money?
While I was also getting social
security,
so I would solve that away.
Very low amount by the way,
because when we didn't get much money.
Yeah,
it's just bullshit.
But anyway,
I paid for gas with cash.
We ate for cash.
We stayed in a motel.
Tonight's at paid cash.
Because you couldn't use your credit
cards too.
They'd be able to track.
Yeah,
exactly.
So when you finally surfaced hodges
surface,
I went to her mother's place and then
what happens then does,
do they try to get you?
Well,
here's what happens.
No,
believe me too.
They try to bring you back,
you'll look big misunderstanding.
Or here's how it went.
About two weeks later we're sitting in
her mother's house and it's a split
level where there's an upstairs and
downstairs in the kitchen.
The window is almost level with the
ground.
You know how it goes and I'm looking out
the window,
we're having breakfast,
coffee and I see it's girl outside
Marion and.
Fuck,
okay.
They found me,
so I went through the garage outside and
there's craig wool hair and he says,
Oh Ronny,
I guess you're surprised it took us so
long to get here.
Ha ha ha.
We thought you're going to go to
Laurie's place.
You never thought you'd come here.
Ha ha ha.
Like nothing happened,
you know?
Right.
So he says,
okay.
So,
uh,
I said,
Greg,
listen,
you're just wasting your time.
I'm not going back.
And he says,
Ron,
I said,
hey,
I don't want to live that life,
man.
It was a terrible fucking life.
I'm not doing it again.
He says,
you blue.
That's a term they use if you leave
without authorization.
And he pulled out this policy.
It's called leaving and leaves and what
it says,
even in leaves leaving and leaves,
that's the name of it.
And what it says in there substantially
is this,
the only reason a person leaves a group
is because they have committed harmful
acts against the group and they went to
remove themself.
So they don't keep on committing harmful
acts against the group.
How convenient.
No Shit.
You can't just leave because you want to
leave.
You have to be aware to the fact that
you know you're working maybe 12,
14,
16 hours a day sometimes not going to
sleep for three days.
You got that raise to 50 bucks a week.
I shouldn't have done it.
It's a nice raise.
So you've,
you,
when you do,
then when they,
when you say you're not going back,
while they try to convince me in,
uh,
it got to the point and says,
guys,
you're wasting your time.
I am not going back.
And I went in town and I saw him a
couple times and they said,
come on,
we'll take out to a nice place to eat.
We'll take you to a movie.
Like they're going to schmooze me into
going back to live that life.
Greg says to me,
Ronny,
look,
you can go to flag.
You will have your own apartment.
You have a kitchen.
We know you like to cook and then you
can train.
Some of the guys had it child.
You can play with the band down there.
Greg,
you out of your fucking money.
You get me down or it's going to be the
same thing.
No,
it won't.
Runny and went on.
So do you think they were just trying to
bullshit you like one?
Not Think.
Absolutely.
They.
So if you got there,
there'd be no apartment.
They'd punish you,
write out a knowledge report.
You can't do this.
Yeah.
Do they want you to stay?
Why do they give a fuck if you leave?
That's what they consider to be a
sensitive particle.
Like these guys.
That was a Paul.
Here's what I mean by that.
Like Dwayne Powell and Daniel Powell,
while I was a father of the chairman of
the board.
Right.
That's a blight.
I mean,
did you ever talk to your son after
this?
I tried to call them once.
I tried to call him after I found out
the pis were following me and after I
heard that you got on the phone and said
if he dies,
let him die.
Don't intervene.
Don't do anything.
This is what you heard,
right?
You can hear it to you.
You design according to your fingers.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Tony Ortega,
underground bunker,
and you can hear these interviews.
Okay?
Okay.
There is public as you're going to get,
but you don't hear his actual words.
Know that this guy would make up that
story to make things up.
Right?
While.
Okay,
let's put it this way.
I'm just playing devil's advocate.
You can play devil's advocate.
The father was interrogated to begin
with.
He told the same story.
The son came in later,
didn't have a chance to talk to his
father.
Told the same story.
Okay,
so you haven't had a chance to talk to
your son.
I called and uh,
an attorney got on the phone and said,
Ron,
David won't talk to you.
He doesn't feel he can trust,
you know.
Let me,
let me ask you this.
As a father,
because I'm a father and your father,
the idea of being estranged from your
kids in that way where your kid hates
you and your kid doesn't want anybody to
save you.
If you die,
do you feel any remorse?
Do you feel like in any way you fucked
up?
Do you ever look at your life and go,
how did I.
How did I lose my connection with my
son?
Listen,
it's written in policy to do what David
did.
Letters,
a policy that says,
listen,
somebody understand that entirely,
but I'm talking to you as a human being,
as a human being,
as a human being.
I thought it was terrible because we had
a good life together,
but do you feel any responsibility?
Do you feel like there's anything you
could've done differently?
Did you get them in scientology?
That's it.
Can I feel like once he got into
scientology,
it's not your fault.
He lives his life.
He's the one who got the power to do all
these things.
I understand,
but you raised them,
right?
I mean,
whatever connection and bond that you
developed with great life together,
we that didn't carry forth in some way.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
obviously I'm not in scientology and
obviously I was not in your situation,
but I can't imagine that you must.
You must have gone over it and looked at
your communications with him and
wondered if maybe if you extended
yourself more,
if you talked more,
if it was there,
something you could've done that
would've prevented any of this.
Joe,
you're dreaming.
I don't mind telling you that.
Okay.
I'm doing it with all respect.
Because you're,
you're,
uh,
you do good interviews.
I've showed you the other interviews and
I,
I've,
I'm happy you got me on the show.
No,
I couldn't have done anything different
except maybe not get them in
scientology.
So you've got the power.
Listen,
there's policy that l Ron Hubbard wrote
and David loved l Ron Hubbard,
and he applies the policies.
We believe all that stuff.
Does he believe there's a politic game?
Are you familiar with that?
No.
What's the fair game?
If somebody goes against the or talks
out against the church and they're
declared a suppressive person,
he can be lied to.
Trick to and destroyed.
No punishment and the person who did it,
but that's not what I mean is the really
crazy stuff like the stuff that sounds
like science fiction about like the
fatals and dropping them in a volcano
and the hydrogen bomb and all that stuff
does.
Does everybody believe that stuff?
I think a lot of people do believe it.
Is it discussed?
No.
You don't discuss that.
No one discusses.
No one discussion.
So when we're sitting around the sea
org,
but no,
let's get thing.
Get back to which pertinent to dish and
that's the policy.
How to operate as a group that won the
fair game.
Policy is written and by the way,
just to satisfy you,
I'll send you soft copies if you need
me.
It's okay.
Here's another one.
A,
if a person does this find or
manufacturer data about the person.
Okay.
So once you've become their enemy kind
of left alone,
you,
you left them,
you're,
you know,
you're the dad of the chairman of the
board.
You're a sensitive particle.
You got a real problem.
That's right.
Okay.
Now you said they took out a bunch of
different website addresses.
Not a bunch,
500.
In other words,
they got 500 iterations or my name
variations.
So no matter what you put in,
by the way,
I have a website,
which I did.
I just did it and it's called the real
ron miscavige.com.
You could see my website,
but if you put any other thing in there,
you're going to get a hate site that
tells you things about me that you think
I was the worst person who ever lived.
Did you write this book?
What was the.
What was the motivation?
Did you want to make money or natural
loading?
Nine.
I wanted to help,
but you didn't make money,
right?
You made some money.
Yeah,
but that isn't the reason to write in a
book.
The reason that the only reason I'd
write a book,
well not me,
the hundreds of families that are
disconnected from the kids.
I understand and I knew if I.
by the way,
what led me to write it was not even him
saying if he dies,
let him die.
I then took a CD with these
interrogations on Daniel Powell and
Dwayne Powell and my wife and I drove
down to Florida that she,
my daughters and I was going to play
these for them because now they're
disconnected from me,
so I went to my daughter's daughter,
Laurie's place,
she's not home.
I went to denise's place.
Her husband,
Jerry,
answered the door,
answer the door about that far,
and he's talking to me.
I said,
Jerry,
I'd like to speak to denise.
Well,
you can't because she's not here.
I said,
well look,
where is she?
Because I got to get in communication
with her.
He says,
no,
you have to go to the church and handle
it with the church.
I said,
Jerry,
for Christ sake and Jerry's as well,
of course they are.
If your wife's in,
you have to be in.
Is that how it works?
Basically,
as you know.
And so he said,
no,
you've got to handle with them.
And he said it's a waste of time.
So I'm talking for about 20 minutes.
And I finally said,
Jerry,
what's up?
What does this mean?
He's.
Well,
I'll tell you why denise and I are
through with you and becky forever.
That was it.
You know what?
Fuck you.
I'm going to do a book and I'm going to
expose what you do to people because if
I did a blog,
who am I?
I'm going to get maybe a couple thousand
people to look at this blog,
but a book I knew that I could get and I
was on 20 slash 20.
I was on the Megan Kelly show.
I was on late night with Seth Meyers,
so we got a lot of exposure,
a lot of books.
A lot of people are seeing what they did
and I'm just hoping enough people do
this so they're going to drop that
disconnection policy because that's a
killer.
So you think if they drop the
disconnection policy,
maybe a lot of the other policies would
be more tolerable.
I think if they dropped the
disconnection policy and allowed you to
talk to your family,
listen,
if they wanted to do scientology and I
could still talk to them,
I wouldn't give a shit.
I'd say,
fine,
do what you want to do.
Look,
but wouldn't it bother you that they
can't leave?
No,
they're public because they're not in
the car,
but you can't really leave if you're
public.
Like,
was Leah Remedy in the Sea Org?
No,
she's a public scientologist,
but when she,
when she left,
she,
she took her whole family with her.
Right.
So they didn't get a chance to pick them
out and say,
look,
you got to disconnect from lists.
That is like one of the things that is
like a hallmark operation of problematic
organizations.
Right.
They separate,
separate you from your family?
I think it's terrible.
I think it's the worst thing you can do
to a person.
Look at them and 45 fucking years
anymore.
Okay.
Right.
I'm 81 years old in January.
I would like to see my family.
I would like to have something,
just pictures of my great grandchildren
on their facebooks.
I've never met these kids.
I don't even know what their names are.
Son of a bitch.
I mean.
And you feel like your kids are going to
be in there forever?
Yeah.
They never expressed any
dissatisfaction.
Well,
when I was in the sea org,
I was not around them and we only would
only communicate through letters or they
would send each other gifts on birthdays
or Christmas or something.
I couldn't get leaves to see them.
At one point my daughter Laurie went to
see David and said,
listen,
if dad can't come to see us,
we would like to go to see him.
So he exceeded.
Just imagine she had to ask him if it's
okay to come and see me and they came to
celebrity center and we up soon,
about four days together and just having
a good time.
Me Cooking,
just enjoying their company and just the
whole scene is really bad.
It's just not okay.
And it's the way it's set up,
it's built into the DNA as to how to
control people.
And you have a threat,
you have extortion,
you have leverage.
And that's what that is.
That is why I wrote the book.
When you look back on your
life joining this in the 19 seventies,
1976 70,
when you look back on your life and you,
uh,
you think about that move,
that initial move of joining,
what goes on in your head?
I don't think about it because there's
nothing I can do about it,
but I can tell you this.
I wouldn't have done it.
In other words,
if I knew then what I knew now of course
I say,
Hey,
fuck you,
man.
I'm not doing this right.
What do you think?
I'm nuts.
Did New people join all the time?
I can't imagine there's very many new
people joining right now.
You know,
unless they're a shepherd or somebody
like that,
or somebody who's never looked at the
internet,
you can't possibly.
And this is what people do,
the checks up molecule googling.
That's very common and you start looking
at anything.
Oh,
what do I want to get involved in this?
You know,
by the way,
in the book I give references to books
that were written in the late 18
hundreds,
early 19 hundreds.
The new thought movement and there's
many,
many datums about life that if you were
a scientologist and you see these as,
wait a minute,
l Ron Hubbard used to say this.
All right,
talking about the reactive mind.
Remember that from dianetics.
When Tim Atkinson,
I'm an amateur guys,
they talk about the subconscious mind.
It records 24 hours a day.
They're talking about the same thing.
He was.
Well Lawrence where I talked about that
and going clear,
he said that it seems like at least some
of what was going on was l Ron Hubbard
trying to self medicate that he was
writing things to try to cure zone ils
probably.
Yeah,
but these people,
I mean you can go on the Internet and
get these books are ninety nine cents
because it's past 75 years.
You can't.
You can't copyright them and of course
you wouldn't know if you weren't a
scientologist.
You wouldn't know which parts that he
took out of that.
But I've run across many,
many things in the books that he just
lifted,
almost copied and pasted it and put it
into what he called scientology.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean if he's trying to get a great
collection of work on how to work the
mind,
the mind works
and it worked then so he knew it would
work now
and so there is something to some of
some of the principles.
That's not a question about it.
Then you think to this day that if you
could remove a lot of it,
if you could filter it down to those
things that are provably work workable.
Do you think it's saveable do you think
like let's say this,
what if you know your son listens to
this podcast and he's like,
what the fuck?
This light,
this world,
who knows this life is not going to last
forever.
What am I doing?
I can't even talk to my dad.
Well maybe I've.
Maybe I've lost my way.
Maybe I get together with.
We tried to figure this out.
Yeah.
And he says,
what can we do to make this better?
I know I'm talking crazy,
but I know I'm talking to this guy.
What the hell you know?
Let's just as an exercise,
what would you do if he said,
let's talk it out.
I talked to him,
I'll talk to anybody about anything new.
People are joining scientology,
we got a real problem.
What do you think is the beneficial
aspects of it that we should keep and
which will get rid of and I think he
would come up with the things that I
come up with also.
So you have wrote about those in this
book.
I tell about four points you could do
and you could sell Bj,
but the chances of that happening are
just show remote.
I wouldn't bet to Shantanu will not even
trying to bet on it,
but do you think that that is just what
happens with people they get into these
positions?
We created an ideology or you.
It's the power.
It's the acquisition of power and then
in order to keep that power,
because I think power is almost like a
drug that's almost like crack cocaine.
You get hooked on it.
You don't want to let go of it right?
And now you have things going to hell
around you.
You're going to do anything you can
perceive to be beneficial to keep it
going and start implementing that and
like buying new buildings and just
making him into these palaces for people
to come and do services and then you
drive by them and there's nobody in
them.
Nobody in them.
Where are they getting all the money to
buy these buildings?
People donate it,
but there's only 20,000
people.
But you have whales,
man.
There are people saying call.
Well,
I'm calling them a and as a matter of
fact,
it's like a gambling term.
It is.
It's somebody who goes to Las Vegas and
they got a lot of dope and they'll blow
it all.
They get crazy.
Come on seven,
right?
Yeah,
it's a whale.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well you have people in there and I feel
no need to mention their names.
I'll,
I'll tell you off the air,
but okay.
I don't want to throw them,
but there's a lot of very wealthy people
and they donate a ton of tonic.
One Guy,
he had a medical procedure.
He sold for something like two,
two point $4,000,000,000.
Who knows?
He probably gave about 50 or $60,000,000
to the church and the church would get
for that.
Do they take them around and one of
those things like one of those old
school king things,
none of those things called the carry
around wells carts.
I don't get a bunch of dudes that cools.
Yeah.
Do you remember?
That'd be dope.
History of the world part one.
Madeline Kahn was on it.
Yes.
Yeah.
One of those.
What are those things called where they
carry around?
I don't know,
but I'll.
I'll check it out and I'll send you an
email.
But anyway,
Jamie,
you'll look it up.
Look,
no,
they get a huge trophy trophy for like
six feet tall and you go on the stage
and get your picture taken with David
and he congratulated.
What about those?
Like big dinner plate gold metals.
That was it called a litter wow.
Like how weird.
The litters of class of wheels vehicles.
A type of human power transport.
A simple litter often called
a king carrier,
consists of a sling attached along.
Two lengths of Poles are stretched
inside a frame.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Now you call the.
I would've never guessed.
I wouldn't have either.
How weird.
Like what is Tom Cruise?
I have to get to get one of those giant
as gold metals.
It's bigger than the Olympics.
Oh,
the medal of Valor Valor.
Well,
that's a different situation.
Let me pay a shot and we tell them,
tell me something.
When,
when you're a celebrity of his stature,
there's no rules.
No rules.
No.
You're,
you're catered to celebrity of my
stature.
Like a minor league celebrity.
What?
Kinda what kinda sweet perks could be
pampered.
You'd be pampered.
Yeah.
Like good seats at a restaurant or
something like that.
Well,
a good that an event.
We'll get that juicy.
Gold metal.
That's beautiful.
Yeah.
I might join.
Just kidding.
A nice metal stand in front of that big
globe and I tell you that is put
together.
That takes a lot of work.
I bet.
Looking at the hands of bastard.
Perfect cheeks could no structure
because 55 years old,
it looks great.
Yeah.
What's the.
What are they keeping him alive?
He looks great.
Like he's a guy that doesn't look like
he's aging.
I know.
No,
he'd be probably workshop.
I'm sure he works out.
When,
when I,
uh,
rate actor,
right?
Admits he ends up tomorrow.
Do you ever see that science fiction
movie?
No one ever didn't.
Great movie.
That's what it's called,
right?
The edge of tomorrow.
The one when he keeps coming back to
life again.
Yeah.
Live,
die,
repeat the county.
That's a fucking great movie that I
think he so wacky that a lot of his
movies,
they don't get the credit they deserve.
You know what I mean?
Because he's so wacky.
People are gross motherfucker.
Well,
no,
he's,
he's a dry.
There's no two ways about it.
It's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is I think that people
don't respect the movie is much like
people that are real connoisseurs of
film.
That's a fantastic science fiction
movies and which are called the edge of
tomorrow.
It's really good.
Three years ago,
maybe four,
something like that.
Wow.
It's a great movie man.
But I feel like if someone with no
controversy attached to them was the
star of that movie would have been
critically acclaimed.
It's a,
it's an amazing film.
It doesn't have any holes in it.
It's a really good.
Well,
I'll tell you,
there's controversy attached to him,
isn't there?
There's a little bit.
Yeah.
If you said there wasn't,
you'd be Glib.
Don't be Glib.
Well,
I know we worked out when he got a house
in Beverly Hills.
I put the gym in,
I got the equipment for the gym in that
House and uh,
well he's a winner.
I mean he's just a winner and he
attributes a lot of those winning
attitudes to scientology.
Yeah,
I mean a lot of his,
uh,
his focus and the way he looks at
things.
That's what I was think of when I used
to think of before I started researching
it and finding all the wacky stuff.
But before I knew what scientology was,
I thought of it as being like a,
I thought of dianetics right.
I thought dianetics was sorta like
Anthony Robbins unlimited power.
Like,
oh,
this is like a guideline for getting
your shit together.
And Yeah.
And that's what I've always wanted to
do.
My whole,
I've always felt like,
ah,
I wish I was more disciplined that wish
I got my shit together more.
Maybe I need to read more books and
said,
read Anthony Robbins,
and then I read dianetics.
I thought they were kind of the same
thing back in the day.
Well,
Anthony Robbins did steal some things
just from scientology.
There's no two ways about it.
And there's also another thing called
[inaudible].
Yes.
I've heard that used in that right now.
Is that,
is that a cult too?
Is.
I mean they're a little bit more.
Look,
I don't know to.
I don't know too much about it,
but I know that there are some people
who've done it who felt they had a lot
of good wins out of it.
Okay.
Well that's the thing,
right?
Like when you look at a guy like Tom
Cruise,
it's kind of undeniable that that guy is
very successful,
very driven.
Motivated,
right?
Yeah.
But don't forget it wasn't just
scientology that did it for him.
He is a talented individual.
I remember the first one he did about,
he was a kid at the valley forge
military academy.
I forget what it's called.
That taps.
Taps.
Yeah.
When I shot that at that man,
I liked this guy ponyboy movie too,
right?
The fuck was that called outsiders?
It's great actor.
Yeah,
and he did one with Paul Newman where
he's a bull shark.
Remember the color of money?
One of my favorite movies.
No,
I mean there's no two ways.
Your body and individually.
I mean,
I met him many times.
He's a nice guy,
so let us.
Does he have any knowledge of all this
stuff when he sees all this
disconnection and if he's a nice guy,
why does it need to step in and go,
hey dave,
we got to fucking cut this shit.
Listen,
I can't imagine that.
He doesn't know about it.
I can't imagine it.
And so he just like a guy like you
separated from your family.
It's beyond his control.
It's with lrap.
Never do anything to go against.
Dave,
why is that?
He continues to David to be the top
spiritual being on this planet.
Look at their.
Saluted each other.
Yup.
That's Jesus.
That's at the event.
Are they in the military?
Pardon me?
Are they know why they knew each other?
Just curious.
Fuck's going on and when I see you in
the morning,
I want to.
We're saluting from now on.
We're going to salute each other.
Fuck it.
If he could do it.
Yeah.
How does that work?
Could anybody salute anybody?
Is that rude?
Is it like cultural appropriation?
Like a person walking around with the
Pocahontas outfit on?
People get mad at,
you know,
anybody can shoot another person.
You might see somebody going up from the
plane and say,
hey,
have a good trip.
But you would do it like almost a
throwaway Chica.
Yes.
Hey,
you fucking way you.
I love you.
Okay.
So the,
the sheehy organization is a military
type organization and you would solute
in the middle of non-ironic,
saluting outside of the military to
seems awful.
Odd.
Yeah.
And you know,
well there's a lot of things John about
it,
but for whatever reason it kept on
going.
And while I think that's one of the
reasons why that man right there,
Tom Cruise.
Oh yeah.
People look at him and go,
this guy's in it.
And he's a winner.
Well now here's what l Ron Hubbard said
that if you,
we should get a celebrity gin because
they are opinion leaders
and what do you do with an opinion
leader?
You want to be like that person.
Right?
And if an opinion leader is a
scientologist,
I'm going to try this out.
I'm going to try what scientology was.
John Travolta like very nice guy.
Seems like a nice guy.
He's literally a nice guy.
And so there's something those guys are
getting out of it.
Yeah.
John Travolta and Kirstie alley and
people like that.
They get,
they get auditing and they get pampered
and enough to follow money rules.
So for them it's almost like they're a
part of like a gang or something.
You're in a clinic,
you're in a clergy.
Everybody kisses your ass is.
Nobody wants to Piss you off if you get
pissed off.
Like Leah.
Well with Leah,
she saw she had go on and shelly was not
there with David when you were at Tom
Cruise's wedding and she said to Tommy
Davis where Shelly and Tommy Davis has.
Listen,
you don't have the fucking ranked as
that question.
Oh,
you gotta get a higher rank.
I thought that was a figure of speech.
That was a figure of speech.
If he would've said,
look at Shelly's off doing a correction
program.
That's why she's not here.
Leah might still be in scientology.
So correction program was shelly fucked
up.
That's right.
And it and everybody in scientology
knows.
Sometimes sea org member isn't seeing if
you say,
well,
doing it,
doing a correction program.
They'd go,
oh,
okay.
That will be it.
So they.
The mistake was they disrespected Leah.
She's very fiery,
not a little bit really fired.
She's from Brooklyn.
She's very fiery.
She's a great person.
She's.
You know how I met Leah hundred meter.
I was in celebrity center in what's
called the president's office and I was
there for some event many years ago.
Is there an election that.
No.
So how does someone get to be president?
No,
it's just you're given the post of the
president of that organization.
Okay.
It's just granted now Leah comes walking
out of this room and she said,
I got the part.
I said,
what do you mean you got the part?
She's,
I got the part.
It says,
who are you?
She says,
my name is Leah.
I got the part in this new show called
the king of Queens.
Hey,
congratulations.
Your neighbor.
A hug.
That's how I met her.
They,
she got the part and we've been good
buddies ever since.
I met her real close to that time as
well.
Yeah,
I'm good buddies with Kevin James.
Oh.
And Kevin James was obviously the leader
of the king queens and uh,
he's a standup comic.
We came up together and uh,
you know,
I'd always a.
I was like,
what is he a scientologist or something
as a gas?
It's all focused.
A little scientology.
Shitty goes on,
get fucking high.
He goes,
yeah,
but he's a funny man.
I use it very funny.
Very funny.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Um,
and he just was like,
Ugh,
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
That was it.
We didn't talk about it.
She didn't talk about it.
I know.
And,
and the show went on no matter what.
A great show.
I enjoy it and I watch very little TV.
That was a show and I could pick it up
anytime and watch it.
Another thing I can watch is the eagles
beaten the giant meltdown at the
meadowlands.
I don't really ever see that.
No,
but eagles are down with three
touchdowns.
They come back and winning the last 13
seconds.
I'm originally from Pennsylvania.
Okay.
You're reminiscing now.
Is that what's going on here?
A little change of pace.
You break the tension.
There's no tension.
I know that.
So listen,
Ron,
good luck with this book.
It's called ruthless.
People can get it everywhere.
You know?
I'm an eternal optimist and I would hope
that one day you'd be able to speak to
your kids and one day he'd be able to
speak to your son and everybody could
work this out,
but I would hope for the same thing and
I guess I'm starting to lose a hope on
that matter because it's the years are
going by now.
I've been out for like five years and I
don't know what's going to change it
other than maybe enough people speaking
out and then dropping that disconnection
politic to Tom Cruise.
Tom Cruise.
Holler at me.
Let's do a podcast buddy.
Come on in here.
Let's trait in this whole shit out.
Yeah.
Thank you Ron.
Appreciate it,
buddy.
Okay.
Thank you.
Hey,
thanks a lot for having me.
My pleasure traded.
How long were we on.